schrödingers katze ist nicht nur ein
bekanntes und wichtiges
gedankenexperiment zur quanten
überlagerung schrödingers katze gilt in
der fachwelt außerdem als ein wichtiger
baustein für moderne quantentechnologie
gemeint sind beispielsweise
quantencomputer oder extrem sensible
sensoren forschungsteams weltweit
tüfteln deswegen daran schrödingers
katze in quantensystemen nachzubilden
ein internationales forschungsteam hat
jetzt eine bislang unbekannte klasse von
quantenzuständen aufgespürt die völlig
neuartige möglichkeiten in sachen
quantentechnologie eröffnen klicks um
science fiction die gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktive die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's er hat sie
willkommen das berühmte
gedankenexperiment von schrödingers
katze beschreibt ein typisches phänomen
der quantenwelt die katze sitzt in einem
verschlossenen kasten und ist so lange
in einem zustand zwischen leben und tod
bis jemand nachschaut vorher ist sie
gleichzeitig lebendig und tod in der
quantenphysik geht es um teilchen die
mehrere quantenzustände zeitgleich
einnehmen können die quantenmechanik
sagt dass der zustand erst dann
eindeutig festgelegt ist wenn die umwelt
mit dem system interagiert wenn also
gemessen wird dazu der physiker gerhard
rempe er ist direktor am max planck
institut für quantenoptik nach erwin
schrödingers idee kann ein
mikroskopischer teilchen wie zum
beispiel ein akt oben sich gleichzeitig
in zwei unterschiedlichen zuständen
befinden
man spricht dann von überlagerung wenn
es zudem mit einem makroskopischen
objekt verschränkt ist kann es seine
überlagerung auch an dieses weitergeben
daraus ergibt sich das beispiel von
einer katze die in abhängigkeit vom
zerfall eines radioaktiven atome
zugleich lebendig und tod sein kann
eine vorstellung die jeglicher
alltagserfahrung widerspricht
forschungsteams weltweit tüfteln derzeit
an quantenkommunikation die es uns
ermöglicht botschaften abhörsicher hin
und her zu schicken und das über große
entfernungen durch solche
überlagerungszustand könnten also quante
netzwerke aufgespannt werden und das ist
gleichzeitig mit einer revolution der
kommunikation wie wir sie heute kennen
verbunden dazu der physiker martin ring
bauer von der universität innsbruck
bringt man ein quantensystem in solch
eine super position von 2 klasse
zuständen so bilden sich sensible
interferenz phänomene welche man für
quantentechnologie nutzen kann also in
etwa so wie zwei wasser wellen die sich
überlagern wenn zwei steine gleichzeitig
ins wasser geworfen werden solche
überlagerungszustand die bislang bei
photonen elektronen und auch bei
molekülen nachgewiesen werden konnten
umfassen genau zwei quantenzuständen
doch es gibt wohl noch mehr wie sich
schon vor einigen jahren zeigte damals
spürten fachleute eine überlagerung form
auf bei der teilchen nicht nur zwei
sondern gleich vier klassische zustände
auf einmal einnehmen können in der
fachsprache ist hier vom sogenannten
kompass zustand der rede dabei handelt
es sich also um einen ersten verwandten
von schrödingers katze bei denen die
vier zustände wie die hauptrichtung
eines kompass angeordnet sind
doch ein internationales forschungsteam
hat jetzt gezeigt dass das noch längst
nicht alles ist die familie um
schrödingers katze ist also wesentlich
größer als bislang gedacht dazu heißt es
in der aktuellen studie diese zustände
beinhalten schrödingers katze und den
kompass zustand als spezialfälle der
niedrigsten ordnung diese neu entdeckten
zustände bestehen aus super positionen
deren klassischen bausteine die ecken
von multi dimensionalen über würfeln
darstellt diese spektakuläre entdeckung
gelang dem forschungsteam übrigens durch
zufall beim experiment mit membran diese
so genannten high cube zustände haben
eine spezielle geometrie das muster
dieser hyper clubs wird immer komplexer
je höher die zahl der überlagerten
zustände wird äußerst spannend auch die
erkenntnis dass so quantenmechanische
interferenzmuster entstehen deren
auflösung kleiner ist als die planck
länge fachleute bezeichnen damit den
abstand der die kleinstmögliche
entfernung zwischen zwei teilchen
beschreibt dazu schreibt das autorenteam
in der neuen studie die quantentheorie
bietet aber ein weg diese grenzen zu
umgehen sie zeigen merkmale in einer
größenordnung unterhalb der planck länge
wenn man das auf unsere erfahrung aus
dem alltag überträgt könnte man wieder
einen vergleich mit dem wasser wellen
heran ziehen auch hier bilden sich
selbst durch den wurf sehr großer steine
ins wasser sehr feine interferenzmuster
der welt dazu der physiker martin
rincker aus innsbruck der an der
aktuellen studie beteiligt war
ein beispiel der stein im wasser sie
man das selbst große steine in der
überlagerung der wellen zum feinen
mustern führen diese können durchaus
deutlich kleiner sein als die steine die
sie auslösen ähnlich ist es bei
quantenzuständen selbst wenn die
zustände an den ecken der hyper würfel
eine mindestgröße haben so ergeben sich
dennoch immer feinere interferenzmuster
je höher die dimension des hyper würfels
wird die fachleute sind sehr
optimistisch dass ihre neuen
erkenntnisse den weg zu zahlreichen
neuartigen anwendungen ebnet die hyper
cube zustände könnten beispielsweise bei
der konstruktion von sensoren mit bisher
unerreichter auflösung hilfreich seien
hierbei könnten die extrem fein
interferenzmuster als maßstabs
markierung dienen die neu entdeckten
quantenzustände könnten aber auch
weitere anwendungen ermöglichen dazu
heißt es in der studie
wir erwarten dass die hyper cube
zustände zahlreiche anwendungen in
fachgebieten wie den quanten sensoren
der quanten informationstheorie sowie
der quantenphysikalischen
grundlagenforschung hervorbringen
quantenphysik die grundlagen die
komplette playlist teil 1 bis 5
unbedingt anklicken anschauen ja und
dann versteht der wahrscheinlich
quantenphysik noch viel viel besser denn
doktor watson erklärt ist und das macht
er sensationell also abonnieren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran